193 countries in the world it's kind of
hard to remember every little just to go
out there while
the National Geographic Bee National
Geographic Bee National Geographic Bee
the treaty on European Union was signed
endangered member of the Turkic language
family room home to over 800 language in
which country that lies northeast of the
island of Bioko a kookaburra Dian Fossey
studied mountain living terracotta
warrior barcelona nigeria taiwan masse
stretch Maastricht is right
and lon no it's Honduras say chuan no
it's one gone blind on Montana yes
you've got that in the nick of time way
is right and that means that Caitlyn
spirit
you go girl
the best represented by
you